y finalmente hoy debe comenzar este
proceso en que juzgado el ex presidente
nicolas sarkozy recordemos hace una
semana debía iniciarse pero fue
suspendido por la ausencia de uno de los
tres acusados los jueces gilbert las
ideas de 74 años que dijo que estaba en
un estado de salud delicado problemas
cardíacos y que venir aquí para él
representaba un riesgo sobre todo dada
la situación de kobe 19 la en la corte
le pidió los exámenes médicos que fueron
analizados y el día jueves este tribunal
decidió que el juez estaba en
condiciones de comparecer así que hoy
debe venir en todo caso se ha previsto
un examen médico cada mediodía de
audiencia para el juez en este juicio
que debe durar tres semanas recordemos
es un caso histórico porque es primera
vez que un presidente de la república de
francia después de la quinta república
que es el régimen que comenzó en 1958 se
sienta en el banquillo de los acusados
jacques chirac estuvo acusado fue
investigado y fue juzgado culpable sin
embargo nunca compareció por
problemas de salud recordemos que este
juicio se inició cuando nicolas sarkozy
en otra de las causas que hay en su
contra fue puesto bajo escucha por los
investigadores y la policía y se
descubrió que junto a sus abogados
intentaron sobornar al juez así ver para
que éste les diera información sobre
otro de los procesos en que estaba
acusado
nicolas sarkozy por eso también se le
conoce como el caso de las escuchas para
esta conversación que tuvo el ex
presidente junto a su abogado ellos
habían contratado una línea de teléfono
para leer la puesta bajo un nombre de
otra persona un tercero y por eso los
investigaron investigadores consideraron
que los métodos de nicolas sarkozy y de
su abogado eran realmente
métodos de delincuentes en este juicio
que como decíamos debe durar tres
semanas el expresidente se expone dicen
algunos hasta 10 años de cárcel todavía
obviamente eso es especulación y también
se habla de varios años de elegibilidad